do you want to be in the Evan man video
so it's wearing a hoodie like this one
of my videos and one of my loyal youtube
subscribers Bala galore balaji not quite
sure how to pronounce it decided to
rewrite the lyrics of spider madness the
old spider-man song with spider-man
spider-man and he rewrote the song to
have it all go eyes Evan man and told my
story and so I thought I might be fun is
is not just to leave that comment and
just let it sit there and waste away but
to turn it into a video and we're going
to put up the lyrics that he wrote and I
want you guys to sing it in the same
tune of spider-man and we're going to
compile all of it and turn it into a
music video that I wanted to have
featuring you guys and your YouTube
channels so we're going to link up the
lyrics I want you to leave it in the
comments a link to your video can be an
unlisted video on your channel or listed
if you want doesn't matter to me where
we can find the lyrics and feature you
and we're going to make the music video
and I'm really excited about it and just
goes to show you guys that when you put
a little bit of extra love to the
comments surprising things will happen
so looking forward to your responses
leaving the comments below and looking
forward to making this awesome video
together thank you guys so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon